[Musique]
qui
patrimoine comme le c'est son 600 mille
mètres carrés bon avec des bâtiments de
type très divers
fermez un bâtiment et couper le
chauffage le temps qu'il baisse
et qu'il soit vraiment en norgel c'est
long donc en fait ajouter des jours à
des périodes longues de fermeture c'est
là qu'on gagne le maximum de calories
[Musique]
ok on a peut-être plus de vacances plus
de temps on pourrait dire pour se
reposer mais ça va pas nous aider au
niveau des études on a quand même besoin
d'une continuité dans l'enseignement qui
qui doit être assurée à la Faculté
surtout quand on a notre âge c'est
important de rester dans un cadre
scolaire et universitaire
[Musique]
au mois de janvier comme au mois de
février il est vraisemblable que ces
étudiantes et ses étudiants auront des
problèmes de chauffage auront des
problèmes de nourriture auront des
problèmes aussi pour se loger
l'université doit rester ouverte
[Musique]